okay today I'm going to talk to you
about fuel cells we're gonna learn what
fuel cells are well they can be useful
the advantages and the disadvantages
okay so to begin with it's really
important to know that fuel cells
essentially they use hydrogen as their
fuel now what they could be used for is
essentially they could be used to power
vehicles now this is meant to be a car
that I've drawn here but essentially
they release energy which can be used to
power vehicles so how do they work so if
we have a look I'm going to show you the
equation that goes with fuel cells so
within a fuel cell we have a simple
reaction happening hydrogen reacts with
oxygen in order to release water so this
is the equation now as this equation as
the reaction occurs we also have the
release of a lot of energy and this
energy could be used to power vehicles
like the one pictured here so let's have
a quick look at this word equation so
our reactants hydrogen oxygen where they
actually come from so we can actually
get to hydrogen by doing the
electrolysis of water so that's using
electric current in order to separate
the two separate the water into hydrogen
oxygen now we could get the oxygen we
can get from the air or from the
electrolysis of water as well so those
are our reactants that are required now
let's have a quick look at the
advantages of fuel cells so the first
massive advantage is the fact that water
is a renewable resource so currently a
cut up most cars use either petrol or
diesel that they burn those are fossil
they come from fossil fuels and they are
running out once we burn fossil fuels we
can't
clannish them we can't make more whereas
when we have this reaction we produce
more water so it's a renewable process
we there's also a plentiful supply of
water available in order to get a
hydrogen from so this is a massive
benefit of using fuel cells compared to
using fossil fuels another advantage is
water is not a pollutant so if we think
about it when we burn fossil fuels we're
producing lots of different gases we're
producing carbon dioxide sulfur dioxide
carbon monoxide oxides of nitrogen and
Surt all of these things from burning
fossil fuels can produce different
problems that produces global warming
sulfur dioxide produces acid rain that's
a poisonous gas that causes
phytochemical smog that causes breathing
difficulties so when we have fuel cells
used instead water is the only product
it's much much cleaner it doesn't cause
any of these effects so none of those
gases are produced only water is
produced as a product which is much
better for the environment so we also
need to learn about the disadvantages
because fuel cells are far from perfect
the first disadvantage is we need a
special and expensive engine so
currently the current technology means
we can't mass-produce cheaply lots of
fuel cells and be able to run them
cheaply so still currently have very
expensive engines also hydrogen is
difficult to store now the reason that
this is it's a gas at room temperature
so it takes up a very large volume
compared to let's say petrol or diesel
so therefore we have storage
difficulties now finally production of
hydrogen or production of hydrogen is
expensive
and relies on fossil fuels now this is a
big problem because obviously one of the
advantages is the fact that it's
renewable and we're not producing any of
these gases that we normally get from
fossil fuels but when we produce the
hide you get the hide in the first place
we are using fossil fuels the reason for
that is we need to carry out
electrolysis now electrolysis reactions
require a lot of energy and that energy
is more than likely going to come from
burning fossil fuels which does release
these gases so currently using our
current energy structures we're still
going to have a problem when it comes to
the production of hydrogen
so overall currently with current
technology fuel cells are extremely
expensive and impractical um so that's
basically the an overview of fuel cells
how they work the advantages and the
disadvantages thank you